[تصفيق]
ترجليه الايرانيه في كندا ان ثوره
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها مدن عده داخل
ايران ما هي الا تراكمات ونتيجه حتميه
لسنوات عاشها الشعب في الظلم والاصطهاد
والاعدامات والقمع
[تصفيق]
اعتقد وبصدق ان ما يحدث الان هو نتيجه لا
عداله والاعدامات والتعذيب التي ينفذها
النظام اعتقد ان هذه من ضمن الاسباب وان
المجتمع الان انفجر وقال كفى يعني كفى
واعتقد ان هذه الاحتجاجات وانفجار
التظاهرات نامل انها ستغير النظام
[موسيقى]
هذا ما حدث لكل مجاهد خلق في مجزره عام
1988 وفي ذلك الوقت كان يوجد ابراهيم
رئيسي واعتقد ان خامن اختار رئيس مره اخرى
لانه يعتقد اننا في
1988 لكن لا نحن ليس كما كنا لقد حان
الوقت وانه القرار الاخير لتغيير النظام
لا رئيس ولا غيره يمكن ان يغير اي شيء
الشهود والناجون من المجزره يعتقدون انهم
سيحصلون على اجابات لاسئلتهم بعد ان ينتهي
هذا النظام ويحصل على الوثائق التي يخفيها
[موسيقى]